the jurogan experience are gyms open out
here
yes okay yeah you can work out you
definitely can't you haven't been
people in la haven't been able to work
out in since
the original thing it's gonna be over a
year they're gonna they're treating
everybody like babies this is what it is
man
they're treating everybody like you're
not allowed to make your own decisions
including business owners that have
spent a ton of money
opening up these outdoor cafes and
outdoor restaurants
and then they don't even supply any
science there's
there's not even they're essentially
autocrats right they're a dictator
they come in they tell you what they're
going to close what they're not going to
close they don't have to show
there's an overwhelming body of evidence
that shows that all this
is spreading from yoga studios we have
to stop yoga
right and and then even then it'd be
like okay
inside yoga is bad but what about park
yoga is that okay
is it okay to do parking lot yoga i
think there's no
data so you have these people that are
idiots they're so dumb they keep getting
busted
going on vacation when they're telling
everybody to stay home
yeah the mayor of austin told people
it's not time to relax
while he was in cabo you know
how crazy that is to go to cabo and be
in a condo in cabo now listen
we can't relax like don't travel stay
away from people all right
take care seth's episode
they're partying javen newsom eating
[ __ ] dinner at a
fancy restaurant in napa with his friend
no social distancing no masks right on
top of each other
doors closed indoors there's a roof
there's a door shut there's a glass
window i mean maybe there's like a part
of that door where you could open up and
you can go outside
that's not indoors [ __ ] yeah or that's
not outdoors outdoors there's no roof
over your head
you don't have a [ __ ] chandelier
outdoors
you see sky that's outdoors you [ __ ]
you can't have a roof and a chandelier
and say i'm eating outdoors
that's a lie yeah you're lying but look
out the window
bro the [ __ ] mayor of chicago same
thing gets busted getting her hair cut
these people are gross yeah they're
gross they keep
getting busted doing the things they're
trying to tell people not to do
and i don't know why they don't think
they're going to get caught they keep
getting caught
it's and it's it's crazy that you i
don't understand it i don't understand
it
there's got to be a better way to do
this that allows people to keep their
businesses
keep their businesses open stay healthy
go outside
i eat 100 uh of my meals
out i have a weird you know lifestyle i
don't eat at home
um and we made friends with some of
these
people these past few months you know i
found some new restaurants
and things like that and once you make
friends with them
and you talk to them a bit you end up
they end up sharing with you like oh
yeah this this but we're
you know we're really struggling we're
on our last leg my father
who's owned a rest who owned a
restaurant for 30 years closed it in
june it's already some other like
corporate janky someone tagged me in a
picture
in ohio yeah wow yeah closed his italian
did he own that restaurant for
almost 30 years it was his entire life
he would
hang out with people at the bar until at
his bar
until you know one two three a.m and he
would start uh
making the sauce and stuff at five or
six
he would sleep for a couple few hours
and then start another day of his entire
everything was that um
and i i have to check on him see how
he's doing but uh but i can't imagine
him doing anything else i always assumed
he was going to do that absolutely
forever but
this is this is the story for almost all
restaurant owners man they just don't
have that they're more like comedians or
artists or something like they spend the
money that they make
you know it's sort of just a different
you take care of so many people
you sort of want to be taken care of so
they like vacationing and they like
doing this and they like doing that so
so many of them and it costs a lot of
money
and for a lot of restaurant owners it
almost is like an art form
like or almost like a source of
entertainment too
because you're not just providing a
delicious meal
you're also giving them a nice
environment you're welcoming them
it's a big part of it in so many of
these places
you know we found this one place driving
around one night
um we drove by this uh
italian restaurant you know we were
starving and like everything was closed
close close close close it was like a
wednesday at
nine right it was a long shot we drove
by this one place and we ended up
the kid worked there was the grandson
the grandfathers the owner the grandma's
inside
answering the phone unloading wine or
whatever like you would see her
if you use the restroom my point is like
they were
they had he was honest you know he's
just they're just open people like yeah
we bought these heat lamps
uh you know this is crazy what do we
have to do it's like an
it was an alleyway and i know for a fact
even though we didn't say it that
they're
they weren't they just weren't having a
good year to say the least
um and uh and it's just frightening to
think that
all these places with all these good
people in la
aren't going to have a chance at opening
up after they spend money on the heat
lamps after they
completely reorganize their entire
structure
has there been any big cities that
decided to
try to stay open most of the pandemic
i don't think so right i don't think
there's any big cities that are run by
republicans
are there uh
big cities run by republicans that are
just
left everything open basically i mean
like mayors yeah
like what about miami it was just
googling me i was like
miami might be open miami well i think
miami
i think florida as a whole the governor
of florida
has basically said listen the cure can't
be worse than the disease
right and it's killing our businesses
it's killing our people
it's like a lot of people are committing
suicide a lot of people are getting
addicted to drugs and
you know and he took a pragmatic
approach and you could disagree or agree
and a lot of people disagree and i
understand that there there is an issue
though that a lot of people who disagree
with him being able to him being able to
do this and opening things up
they're they're financially capable of
surviving
a year or even longer without work
and many of them are actually in the
middle of work and
i don't want to cast any aspersion i
don't want to cast any blame i don't
want i don't want to point any fingers
that's not what i'm trying
to do but uh what i want to say is that
it's
really difficult to even imagine
and this is coming from someone who
doesn't have to imagine it so i know how
ridiculous this sounds
but it's difficult to imagine
the mindset of someone who's losing
everything if you're not losing anything
if your life is basically the same and
this is the problem with some of the
politicians
they they didn't get punished
financially for their city shutting down
they didn't get punished financially for
40 of the businesses going under
i mean sure it's going to be tough for
them to get reelected but they can say
listen we were in a pandemic we did we
could we saved lives that'll be
that'll be the the propaganda that'll be
what they put the pitch
that they saved lives by doing this but
they don't
they don't act the way a person would
act
if their entire life's work
was on the line like your dad in his
restaurant they don't act like that
person would they find a way
to keep things open and keep things
reasonably safe
where they find a way look there's a
there's a better solution here
what we got to do is like keep people
healthier and that'll lower the numbers
of
cases and then it'll also lower the
severity of cases
and that'll allow us to open places up
to a reasonable extent
you know how about we do this how about
we do that how about what is there a
better way to protect people than
[ __ ] handkerchiefs like what's better
handkerchiefs or n95 masks
can we just get everybody an n95 mask it
seems like that's a better way to go
those [ __ ] things like nothing gets
through those but handkerchiefs you
could blow
you ever see there's demonstrations
people do with a handkerchief and a mask
as a mask rather and they they light a
lighter and go
and blow the lighter out and then they
do the same thing with like a cloth mask
a little more difficult then they go to
an n95 mask and nothing happens
right nothing it doesn't get out so that
thing acts as
supposedly some sort of a filter to keep
most of the viral load or whatever i
don't i don't know i don't know how it
works
but when you look at the effectiveness
of that mask
let's say that if everybody had to wear
an n95 mask it cut infections down
x amount percent let's do that let's do
that and
if you're talking about coronavirus at
like in la they were saying
three percent i think it was 3.1 was
coming from restaurants
what if those people were wearing n95
masks
would that drop that 3.1 down to nothing
would it be one
like is one acceptable where people can
keep their [ __ ] living
like you gotta look at these people you
got first of all you gotta look
government's never been able to tell you
you can't work this is unprecedented
this is completely new [ __ ]
government has never been able to tell
like everyone
in an industry i'm in the indoor dining
industry everyone in your industry can't
work government has never had that kind
of power
government is never ever in the history
of the united states of america
had the power to shut all the gyms down
so you can't hey
all you healthy studs and studs and
stuttexes
you you you can't go work out
you're it's not up to you it's not the
people who own that business
sorry i know you've worked your whole
life maybe you did construction for 15
years and saved up
half your pay and put it all away with
this dream of one day opening up this
amazing gym and making your living
off your own business you created
yourself in the community that you live
in
but no no the government knows better
than you
and they get to decide whether or not
you can work
they get to decide whether or not you
take chances whether or not you
feel like you've adequately protected
yourself from the virus whether you
test enough they get to decide and a
curfew
the psychological effect of knowing and
by the way they're not
enforcing it the cops aren't pulling you
over and going what are you doing but
they don't need to the fact that you
know
that you're supposed to have a 10 10 p.m
dude you know what they should do they
should have a loud
siren that plays throughout the city at
10pm
just to freak you out like war of world
style
but i'm telling you when we went from
you imagine tornado sirens in ohio yes
where they
just like that like a tornado siren when
we went from texas back to california it
was like
uh being on vacation and then going to
boarding school psychologically
it was like that it didn't you know
there was no one enforcing the rules
boarding school it's more like juvenile
detention
yeah yeah you you know you're going to a
shitty boarding school except juvenile
detention
at least they feed you more and you're
with a bunch of other fuck-ups you get
to have a good time yeah
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience